in this video I took to the Streets of
London to go to the March against
anti-Semitism and find out what people
are getting up to why they're there and
what they really think make sure to
stick around until the end to hear my
take on the day also remember to hit
like And subscribe because next week
we'll be going to a pro Palestine March
as well now without any further Ado
let's get into the video so we're here
for the protest against anti-Semitism
the March against anti-Semitism as you
can see all this road has been blocked
off with police vans this one is from
Devon there's another one from North so
people have come to police us from all
over the country and I'm sure people
will be coming to the march from all
over the country as well we're going to
talk to some of them find out why
they're here what motivated them to come
uh and uh my cameraman is about to run
over by a bunch of horses you can hear
there's a helicopter overhead one of the
people walking past said to one of the
police officers thank you for looking
after us so so far there's a very uh
convivial friendly mood here uh we
haven't seen anybody being angry but
we'll find out why did you decide to
come out
because we wanted to stand with our
community because we're really concerned
about the increase in anti-Semitism in
this country and around the world so I
check it your Jewish then yes and uh
when you talk about anti-Semitism what
do you mean
specifically anti-Semitism is attack
against Jews for purely being Jewish
have you experienced something like that
you're nodding yes I have I was on the
tube once and I was wearing my Star of
David and this was five years ago
someone screamed at me and ripped my
Star of David off do you think there's
been an increase in recent uh weeks
since the seber 7th attex very much so I
was in Australia and they were screaming
outside the op house saying gas the Jews
it's awful we have a great aunt who so
you were actually there when that was
happening wow you're here for the for
the anti-Semitism March or the March
against antisemitism I should say why
did you start to come uh well I probably
should say I'm not Jewish myself but um
I do with some Jewish friends and just
reading recently the riseing
anti-Semitism going to the me I think
it's like over 1300% I take it you're
going to the anti antisemitism protest
what made you decide to come we're fed
up with anti-Semitism and the racism
that's going on on the streets every day
every Saturday for the last 5 weeks and
we this is a country that profoundly
isn't racist and we're fed up with it
and when you say the racism What
specifically you referring to every
Saturday so the Saturday where clearly
pramas supporters are going out there
supporting terrorism in a country which
is democratic free and unified and it's
obscene it's actually horrific feel like
there's a bit of a clash of
civilizations that we're all waking up
to at the moment one of the things that
really stood out for me from the day was
the fact that so many people without me
even prompting them brought up the fact
that they were extremely disappointed
with the mainstream media's coverage of
this conflict and these issues the BBC's
at a shocker start to finish even then
you see Jeremy Bowen again the other day
doubling down on just complete falsehood
so on that side of it you think to
yourself no you can't really trust
what's being portrayed there and even
then now even someone that um comes out
the mainstream media always portrays it
immediately is far right it's
immediately like word addition it's like
no you can believe that you know Israel
defending s is a completely valid view
without that being far right so I think
the mainstream media is kind of a bit
lost on this topic a bit at the moment
the BBC has an awful lot to answer for
even Sky the abrasive nature of their
interrogations of you know they take
Hammer at face value but seem to
question everything the IDF an
incredibly professional military uh uh
institution uh everything that they say
they question and yet Hamas spurts out
numbers and they take it at face value
so I think there's a lot to be answered
for I think that they've been so
divisive in the representation of
numbers and facts and so many people
watch the media blindly and don't do
their homework and I think it's a very
dangerous precedent to start just giving
shooting off bits of information and
taking sides when the world is watching
you and one of the things obviously has
I think motivated a lot of people to
come out today is the protest we've seen
over life last six weeks is that been a
factor in why you came yeah I mean also
I think I only the mainstream media are
publishing as much as showing as many
videos with people dra chance of like
from The River To The Sea Paris is free
um there's been Hamas Flags I've seen
other news sources but not Sky News or
BBC for instance that's interesting so
do you think the the media the
mainstream media covering this fairly no
I don't the other thing I noticed and
this could be a feature of the fact that
this very difficult conflict to resolve
obviously but also maybe because of the
types of people who are attracted to
protests and we'll find that out as we
go to More protest in the future is that
whenever I asked people whether they had
a solution or how this was going to be
solved almost nobody seemed to not only
have an idea but it felt like nobody had
really thought about that in the first
place the problem is with this conflict
I saw a fantastic uh thing in the times
the other day to explain the conflict in
two sentences with with the uh Irish
situation they managed to negotiate a
resolution because both parties wanted
peace ultimately in this case Israel
wants peace ultimately the other side
unfortunately does not want peace they
want us destroyed and that's what they
are saying when people walk around from
The River To The Sea it means that they
want the Israel annihilated they do not
want peace so how do negotiate with
somebody that does not want peace that's
the problem and so how do you think this
this is going to play out from here well
the problem is it's not everybody is bad
there are Hamas who is bad and they have
actually um been very bad to the
Palestinian people as well and Israel
contrary to everybody's belief has
helped Palestinians and helped people
and if you walk in Israel it is the most
non uh it's it's so mixed and every
every um religion nationality walks
freely in Israel has jobs Etc okay so
Israel is not what people people are
ignorant and do not understand they
should go to Israel and see what's going
on and they are quite happy to to uh uh
have people live alongside each other
and live together and to find a way to
peace but uh it's it's the terrorism
terrorists who do not want the peace
people of Israel to survive that that
caused the problem for the uh average
Palestinians do you believe in the
two-state solution but I do know this
that Israel is no fault I mean Israel's
got so much information and so wise
because they've been fighting for their
existence for the probably the whole of
History you know ever since the
Holocaust and tell a really good person
a spokesperson for Israel I'm so sorry
thank
you you thanks guys thank you appreciate
thank you thank you hello mate hello
Caroline Glick from Jerusalem she gives
a very good update on a reality love to
to me thank you very much ultimately I
think Hass needs to be eliminated but we
also need a political settlement at the
end of it that's how this ends I would
love to see a two two State solution uh
Palestinians and Israelis living side by
side but you know I'm not a diplomat I'm
not a politician um you know I'm just a
punter observing all of this and and
hoping it comes to an end like everyone
else
[Music]
does can I ask you a couple of
questions is it your sign what does the
sign mean it's a t dictum and what does
it mean it has many
interpretations can you give us some of
them that Israel and the Jewish people
are
kind and that we must not
confuse to who who in this conflict is
the kind ones and who are in this
conflict are the cruel and is it is I
don't know I am not familiar with this
at all so this is a genuine question is
there an element of this that sort of
says sometimes you have to be strong uh
to defend yourself for example is that
part of it yes being nice is not always
the the the best
option find me on Facebook I thought you
were just going to give me your bank
card there mate thank you John
appreciate it thank you so we've been
shunted down the side Street uh cuz the
main protest is happening over here and
the police have cordoned this bit off I
don't know why hopefully we can follow
around and join it from there let's go
do you know what's interesting is
everybody we've spoken to is really Keen
to get their peace out it's almost like
people feel like they haven't been heard
um which is interesting uh I wonder see
this is the first one and we need to go
to um a pro Palestine protest as well
watch out um we need to go to a pro
Palestine protest as well uh and see
whether that's the case there where
people really feel like this is the one
opportunity to say something but the
other thing that really strikes me is
how many people feel that the mainstream
media has been covering this completely
wrong and just not reflecting what's
been going on at all and that's I mean
it speaks to the success of our channel
so far because we're trying to do
something that's the opposite of that
and it's amazing how many people here
feel that um so we'll be we'll keep
talking and find out what people
say
I see you sign you've got not my BBC uh
what have you made of the way the BBC
has covered this conflict oh it's it's
been pretty appalling really um they
they try to give the illusion of being
impartial but uh there's a sort of
latent bias that sometimes I wonder
whether the correspondents are actually
aware of it an apology from the BBC a
BBC News as it covered initial reports
that Israeli forces has entered gaza's M
hospital we said that Medical Teams and
Arab speakers were being targeted this
was incorrect and misquoted a reuter's
report the worst offender is Jeremy boen
who's got a long history of of
misreporting and
inaccuracy and uh what was um sort of
published yesterday what the video of
him being interviewed yesterday was just
appalling really I think it was measured
throughout I didn't raise the Judgment
but you said that building had been
flattened oh yeah well I got that wrong
because I looking at the pictures that
was my conclusion from looking at the
pictures and I was wrong on that um but
I don't feel particularly bad about that
and why do you think this is why do you
think the BBC is not covering this
conflict fairly in your opinion um I
think it's mediocrity in actual fact you
know I don't think that it's necessarily
just sort of anti-Semitism I don't like
to put it down to that I think they've
got people who just don't sufficiently
understand the Middle East they don't
understand Israel well enough they don't
understand the the Arab side so uh you
know that doesn't that's not a good
recipe they I think certainly amongst
the English journalists they don't have
enough sort of they don't have Hebrew or
Arabic speakers as far as I can tell
it's just not good enough so I don't
know what's going on but we've all ended
up being penned in in this tiny space
not going to do the inappropriate joke
that I could uh and uh I don't think
this crowd is actually moving anywhere
maybe it is a little bit we'll find
out
where's your flag from Iranian an
Iranian flag so you're Iranian or uhhuh
Iranian Jews or just Iranian so what
brings you here today just beside Jewish
people uh against the terrorism against
the Islamic regime in Iran which is
father of Hamas that's it so you you
believe that Iran is supporting Hamas
and funding them Etc not Iran or not
Iranian yes we are against Hamas cuz we
know that if Islamic regime stop to
support stop supporting Hamas the war
will stop you know I hope
Palestinian understand that you are not
against them you are against Hamas and
besides all Jewish people around the
world so we tried to join the main March
uh we got pushed out to the S side so
now we're on the embankment and uh this
is a massive protest there's a of people
you can see them coming from there but
also look down there I mean the whole
road is basically full of people heading
down so we'll join them and find out
where this uh Journey takes
us do you know what's interesting we'
been watching protest for about 6 weeks
I don't remember seeing this many
British flags and there are quite a few
there's a guy draped and one over there
there was a guy holding one it's quite
an interesting observation I don't know
if this is right I haven't been to the
pro Palestine protest yet but I'm
surprised just to see well not surprised
but it's a it's a contrast certainly
feels like a
contrast why have you got a British flag
um British born and raised so here to
support my country and hopefully see a
reduction in uh the anti-Semitism that
I've witnessed you've witnessed
anti-Semitism yourself well on on the
marches on the on the palace Pro marches
I don't know what's going on but I'm
excited there has been a lot of standing
on this quote unquote March like we've
been pretty stationary for most of it um
we've now made it back to the main March
and we're standing again I don't know
what's going
on Bella uh you've been going to the Pro
Palestine protest uh what what has that
been like it's been really upsetting and
distressing so I was there yesterday
again and we saw anti-Semitic tropes on
display genocidal chanting just a very
um disturbing atmosphere and very
aggressive and I have to say it's so
different to this it's very peaceful
lots of families here no chanting no
anti-semitic signs um so really happy to
be here and yeah just such a brilliant
crowd but a huge contrast to yesterday
this is the first prct I've been to I
have to say the lack of chanting has
been disappointing we we need some kind
of yeah there might be a bit I need to
be a little bit I agree hopefully
everyone will kind of get more into it
but you've been going and you've been
actually calling people out about stuff
and you you made it out would you did
you feel safe being there yeah I felt
relatively safe um no one was like
abusive or aggressive to me but I just
feel like I have a duty to to stand up
to hatred and Prejudice when I see it I
think we all do and at the moment I'm
I'm slightly disturbed by the fact that
there's a lot of Silence around this
we've seen a massive increase in
anti-semitic hate on our streets and a
lot of people are just not saying
anything and you see politicians they
you know they come out with harsh
rhetoric but nothing's really being done
so I just think we all have a duty and a
responsibility to to call that out when
we see
it as a committed Christian I believe we
know that God gave the land to the the
Jews and when are you coming to
Australia Constantine uh February
February yeah yes February you're going
to be interviewed by my wife as it
happens oh am I yes at the now I'm
[Laughter]
[Applause]
excited we walked over from the protest
in the East part of London it goes all
the way along the embankment over to we
are in Trafalga Square now uh and then
uh all the the way down to White Hall
Big Ben number 10 Etc so it's a massive
protest hundreds and hundreds tens of
thousands of people at least we in trala
square now and there's a Palestine flag
so let's go and have a look what's going
on
there there's also some Israeli Flags
over there so uh this could get tasty
over there you have some Jewish people
with Palestine flags and on this side
you have some uh protesters against
anti-Semitism and they're being
separated from each other so this is Jew
on Jew violence
basically I mean they're surrounded by
police I'd love to talk are we allowed
to talk to
them we can't interview
them okay all right not the minute okay
it's interesting that they're so well
protected cuz no one's no one's
attacking
them
[Music]
[Applause]
so those guys are from an organization
that thinks Jews shouldn't have a
country at all because that's against
God um and these boys don't agree it's
fair to say so there's a bit of a
standoff we talked to the police asked
them if we could interview them and they
were just like it's getting a bit heated
so uh no luck so far I was just curious
why there's a standoff it's not a
standoff it's like we just happen to be
by they're there and it's not it's
there's no rationale to it okay if they
would have steep one foot in Gaza they
wouldn't exist two seconds they would be
killed that's probably true yeah and yet
they have their particular beliefs and
everyone's right to everyone's like you
know they have their beliefs so I guess
people here are just saying that they're
wrong is that not wrong they're crazy
okay they're crazy I'll listen and watch
you all the time appreciate it thank you
very much mate hi there do you mind if
ask you a couple of questions of course
you can uh so what flag is that it's
Kurdish flag I'm Kurdish I'm Kurdish
from Kurdistan but you cannot find
Kurdistan on the map it's divided
between Iran Iraq turkey and Syria I'm
here to support my Jewish brothers and
sisters what is the difference between
hamash and Isis or Isis and alqaeda or
alqaeda and
Hasa we're headed to White Hall to the
Senate half which is just down there
near uh number 10 down street as you can
see there's a big March over here as
well uh so it's been actually surprising
to me how big it has been uh you can
hear people singing uh but it's it's
very um it's very calm it's very very
calm for what is a protest very relaxed
so that's a cheer for the police here
which is an interesting experience uh
and as you can see there are a lot of
police around this is the senat off by
the way it's uh fenced off like
[Music]
crazy they are our friends they are our
neighbors they are our colleagues they
are our kith and
kin you are
interwoven into the weft and the war of
our great
nation a Britain where British Jews are
afraid is not
Britain you're part of the Declaration
against antis tell us what that's about
and why you're here yeah we set up the
October declaration in the aftermath of
7th of October because it was obvious
that British people need to pull
together and make a really powerful show
of support for British Jews the March is
which happened straight away on the
streets of this country not only felt
like people celebrating mass murder
after the worst terrorism of Our Lives
they've been a festival of anti-Semitism
with anti-semitic placards and chanting
that I never thought I'd hear my life um
which was cruel and shameful and hateful
towards Jewish people so um we set up
this declaration which stands against
anti-Semitism it's full British Jews and
very importantly we ask the media to
call Hammer is and law and fact which is
a terrorist organization and it's
currently signed by over 880,000 British
citizens um and this is this is what we
do as a country you know we're tolerant
Democratic we're proud of Liberty and we
stand with people and we write letters
so here we are end of the day it's
getting dark as you can see uh the
Crowds Are dispersing there were we saw
a bunch of speeches in Parliament Square
there was somebody from the government
somebody from the opposition uh the
chief Rabbi spoke a bunch of other
people it was low energy let's put it
that way so people are just there like
no chance broke out people clapped in a
kind of half people were happy to be
there they agreed with what was being
said a lot of the people here holding up
um signs with pictures of hostages and
stuff but there's really zero anger here
that we saw the vibe here has been like
it's not been mostly peaceful it's been
entirely peaceful from the moment we
arrived to to the very end there's
nothing going on and from what we've
been told by the police there was
someone between 105 and 120,000 people
which is a lot that's kind of the
reflections of on the on the day we
spoke to a lot of people most of them
were making kind of reasonable points in
a reasonable way do I think what we saw
today's representative of most people in
the UK I actually do think that's true I
think uh British people generally tend
to be you know stiff upper Li quite
reserved um and so the the more violent
and aggressive protest that we've seen
you know in the summer of 2020 and in
the last 6 weeks whether there's
aggressive chanting people with all
kinds of racist and and U angry violent
rhetoric Etc there was none of that here
and I actually think this is much more
British and the thing that really stood
out for me from the very beginning is
now look to be fair we haven't been to
any pro Palestine protest yet we are
going to go uh next week and uh we'll go
more so we'll see whether this Bears out
in reality but when I've been watching
footage on social media I haven't seen
many British flags at the Pro Palestine
protest and it was very noticeable that
there were so so many British flags in
the crowd uh people carrying flags being
draped on them Etc so that I thought was
very interesting and there was one guy
in particular I remember early on who
said that he thought that this was a
clash of civilization so I think there
are quite a few people who feel that
this isn't just about what happened on
October the 7th it's not just about the
conflict in the Middle East it's
actually a reflection uh on what's
happening in The Wider world and
ironically a woman dress R and a British
flag has just walked up behind us my
sense is that increasingly people are
starting to become aware of the fact
that how can I put this diplomatically
that we we have imported a lot of uh
ways of Behaving that are fundamentally
counter to the way that we do things in
this country how does the fact that this
is the second biggest uh protest uh
against anti-Semitism since the second
world war reflect on where we are I
think it reflects on the fact that we're
not in a good place and um the policies
that have led to this situation uh are
the ones that the British public have
been concerned about for a long time
concern you know I came to this country
in
1996 at that point 3% of the British
public thought that immigration was a
major issue fast forward to today you
know the overwhelming majority I would
imagine of the public or certainly a
majority of the public are concerned
about that issue and that's because
they're seeing the impact of mass
immigration particularly uh from certain
parts of the world and this is something
that never gets said but nor o
immigration is the same uh I actually
saw a tweet from Elon Musk the other day
about how we need to increase
immigration of people who are
hardworking smart talented Etc and I
completely agree with that we also need
to stop illegal immigration uh and we
need to reduce immigration that is not
beneficial to this country and I think
what we're seeing on the Streets of
London and many other Western cities is
that's the case how do you solve Israel
I have no idea how you solve Israel or
Palestine uh and actually what was
interesting uh today and this may just
be a reflection of a how challenging an
issue that is and B the kind of people
that are drawn to protest and marches
Etc in general but um no one really
seems to like we ask that question of
quite a lot of people no one really had
an answer to it um my sense is Israel is
probably going to continue to do what
it's trying to do which is eliminate
Hamas um and they'll probably eat the
international condemnation if they have
to uh and carry on so this is our first
time doing any kind of Street stuff uh
and I'm very keen to go and see some Pro
Palestine protest so it' be very
interesting to see today's protest
contrast with what we see next week
smash that like button make sure you
subscribe support the show on locals
we're going to be bringing you more
exciting content over the weeks and
months to
come